the gyro can experience well I'm
optimistic because you're optimistic
when you tell me three to five years
from now we're possibly looking at some
sort of a breakthrough where things
start moving into the public eye where
people are really taking a consideration
like this is this is real technology
that you should we should all start
implementing on our particularly on
people that are older and ailing well
right I mean at the moment though even
though there are some things in clinical
trials we always have to remember that
the most challenging areas are still at
an early stage so that's why I make and
not only do they have to individually
get you know it's all the way through
your clinical trial so they're safe but
also they have to be combined you know
each of these things individually can be
applied to a small subset of the
population that happened to have you
know early onset diseases arising from
maybe congenital acceleration of one
particular type of damage right but then
to work to be useful for the people who
don't have any congenital problems who
are aging and normal rate
we've got to actually combine them all
and of course that's going to throw up
on unanticipated interactions so that's
why I put this timeframe as far out of
17 years and even then with only 50
percent probability right but the
anticipation is the thing that's where
the shit's gonna really at the fact you
know where there's gonna be this
enormous turbulence and society arising
from the knowledge that this is coming I
for one am very excited about living in
be 500 I think I can get a lot of [ __ ]
done I learned about myself you know
people I think it's I think it's I I
think it makes no sense to think about
what one's gonna be doing in the distant
future
yeah people there was one time I was on
stage but I guess a five or six years
ago and somebody from the audience for
about the thousandth time asked me um
you know how long do you want to live
I just lost it's like sometimes
questions just one more time to other
okay I've got a question for you
I said I said right what time do you
want to go to the toilet next Sunday
like incredulity and I said yeah you
haven't the first idea why I asked you
that question D but it's exactly the
same kind of question yes you know you
may have an opinion about what time you
expect to go to the toilet next Sunday
because of habits but having an opinion
about what time you want to go to the
toilet is completely crazy so you are
going to have better information on the
topic near at the time and you're going
to be able to act on that information
it's exactly the same and also the idea
of how long you want to live is going to
be irrelevant if they can repair disease
and fix all these issues it's just gonna
be the quality of life precisely I mean
having an idea of how long you want to
live even stating that the quality of
life is going to be like a young adult
physically and mentally you know it's
crazy to have an opinion because it's
going to be determined by other stuff
[Applause]